and we're up
hey how's it going ryan how's it going
aaron so battlefield it's a thing may 6
is when it's happening uh the
announcement for the next battlefield
game the future of battlefield we are
here playing some bad company 2 which
is i don't know it's my favorite
battlefield game of all time
um it's largely because i just really
love the way this game is designed and
you know the way that it feels i think a
lot of people though like
are old
battlefield 2 fans
uh
there was a lot of battlefield between
you sorry just focusing kill anything
there's been a lot of battlefields over
the years uh and people don't really
know what to expect from this
announcement it's just
not clear what they're gonna talk about
um so we're gonna be watching aaron play
some bad company 2 which i think yes is
our probably mutually favorite
battlefield game um although i think we
appreciate pretty much all of them with
certain issues in the later ones but
we'll be talking about the announcement
and go into the chat seeing what people
think there too what are your favorite
battlefield games what do you think of
the new one what do you want in a new
one
um
and what are your theories on what we're
actually gonna get i'm gonna switch us
over to the
gameplay uh right right now oh you
missed all that sweet tank all right
here we go we're gonna get it
here we are on a this was a late release
in the uh oh yeah of course you cut to
it when i died
hey i make i have not played battlefield
in a while um i i stepped out late in in
four i went back briefly for the cte and
just wasn't super in love with four it
just felt like kind of a regurgitation
of three without making significant
changes
um which is why
we're playing bad company today because
this is a game that i love
far more
i'm gonna just
not try not die here for a second um
okay so what are they going to talk
about on the six uh right now
it's speculation um there's a lot of
options there were rumors this is just a
rumor there are rumors flying around
before that they're gonna change the
time period
a lot of people have been wanting a
world war ii battlefield for a while i i
don't know i'm not sure if people really
want world war ii do you remember
everybody
played world war ii games for over a
decade and were just sick to death of
them
there was a rumor for a while that there
would be a world war one game which i
find
unlikely just because world war one
would not deliver the attachments and
kind of customization that people have
come to expect in the battlefield title
then there's the probably more likely
scenario that we're gonna get a
get it nope there's a more likely
scenario that we're gonna get uh oh yeah
maybe the goal
2143
there have been easter eggs and
battlefield 3 end game in battlefield 4
final stand
that both hinted very strongly that
maybe another
21 something yeah it doesn't work dice
has been sneaking the
um 2142 easter eggs into the games for a
little while now and it will absolutely
not be surprising if that's what we get
but you know aaron we've talked about
this around the office quite a bit i i
personally think that
the graphics have gotten better the
consoles have gotten better
it's
i would be totally fine with going back
to world war ii and
you know replaying some of those
you know
the like omaha beach and
uh not hell i mean anything from 1942
would be great to play again
and
that's that's where i would want to go i
think it's been long enough and honestly
everything else has been doing future
stuff lately
and
i think just like you said there was a
period where it was all world war ii
well now it's all future and it's like
do we really need more future right now
i'm i'm looking forward to titanfall 2 i
loved the first titanfall
and you know call of duty is obviously
going in that direction too and
i think it would be kind of classy for
dice to back off and do a little bit
more
go back to the past a little bit yeah i
mean i think you'd also mention that
titanfall who destroyed our own what
what are you doing people
i mean
they're they're fighting over the
helicopter i'm not going to say bad
companies you didn't have problems yeah
definitely it definitely like hadn't
refined the helicopter game at this
stage
but i think conceptually these are some
of the best maps in the battlefield
series but anyway so ryan you had said
that we've definitely got mixed opinions
in the chat we've got uh master of the
hero saying no more world war ii on
twitch and over on youtube we've got uh
um
screaming patriots saying we have no
good world war two games on new gen and
i i kind of agree with that right now
i mean if they're gonna do world war ii
i think the only thing that they can
really offer that that hasn't been done
already is
um
nobody's really done battlefield hd
world war ii
maybe like you know you might we didn't
have destruction in 1942. so just adding
the destruction and also the effects we
talked about this earlier that um it
wasn't until battlefield 2 that the
the sound was there to be shocking like
you could be standing next to a tank and
when it fired there was a ringing in
your ears and you kind of couldn't hear
for a second like
having that kind of effect which is now
even kind of old uh but have that
transferred back to world war ii i think
would be kind of cool yeah i mean having
it be frightening for a panzer to come
down the street because
like if the panzer with the current
frostbite sound design and the current
level of hd graphics would be very very
different like if you if you go back and
actually look at 1942 i think it was
released for free
on origin
i i'm not joking when i say it looks
like an iphone game it literally like
you you forget it's been a while you
forget how primitive those graphics were
back then so if they did go back to
world war ii
they might have something to offer just
because
like we haven't seen world war two it in
in the level of graphics that frostbite
can do on the other hand here's what i
would rather have them do the
photogrammetry yeah so now that they've
done photogrammetry for um
star wars battlefront
uh i don't know if you're gonna get your
circle straight on here aaron yeah i
don't know if i reversed my controls
this might not go well okay folks i'm
not bear with it i i did
i did tell everybody that i've not
played this in a while um i actually
need to invert my flight controls
i will apologize to whoever's my
co-pilot real quick i need to
land and
oh
invert my flight controls okay well
aaron's working on inverting his okay
photography
go back to photogrammetry uh yes we've
gotten the the graphics technology has
gotten better i think it's i think it's
fair to say that between um bad company
two and battlefield three oh geez there
you go buy a helicopter uh at the very
least the controls tightened up
i think oh no let's talk about
photogrammetry and if they did so let's
say they went back and did vietnam right
okay like if they did if they did uh not
you know bad company had a really great
vietnam expansion but if they did
battlefield vietnam again now i think
that could take a lot of the boxes i
think
a battlefield vietnam could get the
photogrammetry
from battlefront and it would look
gorgeous
it has asymmetrical warfare there's some
level of customization
it's a place that we haven't been since
the bad company 2 expansion
i think that would be a which by the way
was a great expansion yeah i mean i
think that would be a really cool play
if they went with vietnam
um i'm not saying that they
will oh i got it
get get get
oh oh here we go here we go here we go
he's smart he bailed out
uh that was really i mean if you were
infantry in bad company two and a
helicopter came at you that was the only
way to really do it was tracer dart oh
yeah didn't didn't have
multiple opportunities to lock on oh man
they it got to a point in battlefield 4
where it was like how many different
ways could you lock onto a helicopter
oh like one of the biggest problems with
with corvalco is helicopters are really
a pleasure to fly once you get the hang
of them
but
keeping them in the air for any length
of time
is damn near impossible
and
then the weird thing on that though is
the players who are really really good
at the game
like somehow keep them in the air
indefinitely so you've got this weird
thing where it's really hard for
low-level players
um to fly the helicopters they like they
just crash 10 times learning how to do
it but then you've got high level
players who just dominate like the whole
air game probably needs a little bit of
a
rema jiggering
i had to call it anything little little
rima jiggering
okay so let's start out the chat what
what do people want to see in this
announcement chances are we're gonna get
probably if it follows their usual
pattern we're probably gonna get single
player that's usually the first thing
they talk about oh boy man i didn't even
touch the battlefield 4 single player or
hardline
i played i played a good chunk of the
way through three
and that was about it yeah i don't know
who who who liked the single player out
there who thinks the single player has
made
battlefield a better game
because that will fight you
so far i i'm not
i'm not seeing much in the chat in the
way of support of single player
i mean i just i think just patently it
didn't it didn't make the game better
like i think if anything they just took
budget away from multi-player
um but yeah so
you want to go down the list the these
are all the the battlefield games
they've been over the years we should
read them off just for refresh people's
memory master the hero on twitch says i
love the single player in battlefield 4.
so there we go we've got a vote for it
what did you love about the single
player in battlefield 4. i know that the
graphics were good the graphics would
that's actually true
that's that's true
after this i'll switch to another map uh
we're just playing conquest right now
but everybody knows that and uh also on
twitch there's a two cs2 envy saying um
battlefield past present and future you
can warp to any battle you want and you
and i have talked about this often on
the idea of
like a 10 map multiplayer or 12 map that
has like three of the best from
everything from 42 to the present i
think that would be a smart move on
their part oh i totally can't even if
that was just like battlefield
remastered whatever they want to call it
like that you know you'd have maybe
limited loadout expansion possibilities
from
like era to era but to have all of them
all of them in hd and actually have to
and be able to switch between them sort
of from match to match i think would be
kind of cool yeah the way that they did
the halo remastered although
you know without all the problems
so jill valentine on the youtube chat
says single player only matters for bad
company series what do you think about
that aaron i
totally agree because bad company had
personality and and there weren't a lot
of other battlefield games that were
anything other than generic mc military
shooter guy
doing generic military shooter stuff
um
other than that though i'd like i've
always said i was actually really really
loved battlefield 3's co-op campaign i
thought that was something special um
particularly i thought fire from the sky
was a really cool template or something
yeah yeah that was that was something
that could be great so fire from the sky
um
was basically a helicopter assault up a
valley
and you fought waves of of enemy
ai through a series of objectives and
vehicles would come onto the map as he
played now
i think that if they took that concept
into
multiplayer
uh you know more like titanfall with
minions that would be incredible now
i'll admit the way that it actually
played out in co-op was a lot of times
people were trying to get an unlock
that you could only get from flying it
so a lot of people would uh
get spawned into the gunner seats
and then
bail on the mission oh yeah because of
the but that wasn't the mission's fault
that was the unlock
tree's fault
that was bad design is what that was so
if they're going to do a campaign i
would just much rather have it be
that's sort of that sort of stuff
he just got hit by the
fan blade
on the the wind turbine that was awesome
but yeah i mean that was that was the
other thing that they did um towards the
end of the
bad company two period they added onslot
mode where they
made a
co-op players versus bots sort of
rush style mode
um
i could absolutely see another
battlefield game having minions i think
it would add a lot you know one of the
weird things about say battlefield 3
siege of shanghai that always honestly
kind of weirded me out was the fact that
there weren't civilians running and
fleeing for their lives
um i think developers have maybe i don't
know if they've shot away from it for
computing power reasons
or because they just didn't feel
comfortable stomaching like civilians
being in the mix it could be both
um
but i just really think battlefield 4's
maps felt kind of empty and soulless
and i think having minions even if it's
civilians on those maps or newer maps
could
just give it a level of realism
and a level of immersion that it's
lacking currently
here's an interesting question from
mcjamie dodger will the player count be
more than 64 players in the next one
now i know you have feelings about 64
players
i don't have feelings about 64 players
so much as
i i think every map has an ideal player
count i don't think it's fixed i don't
think that there's any
need for there to be 64 unless a map
justifies it so there was a lot of maps
in battlefield 4 that
just were scatter shot they just didn't
feel like they had good flow to them and
you were always getting shot in the back
and i think part of the reason you
always getting shot in the back was
because there were 64 people on maps
where
it just didn't support 64 people
um
so i think the answer is there's no
right number
there's no one right number it just
depends on how your maps are designed i
would rather have
maps that are designed
very strong
where are you right in front of well
that's actually an interesting point and
when you talk about like the map design
factor i mean we had a lot of fun last
summer playing the
on ps4 the free to play planetside 2.
yeah and that is an example where the
maps are absolutely enormous and having
hundreds of players is totally fine
because the
the flow of the battle is sort of spread
out yeah those ma plant side two does a
great job of channeling people to
objectives in a way that
is compelling and is is uh i'm totally
gonna get sniped
you know it's it it does it in a
compelling fashion it channels people
together in the right ways so it's not
scatter shot people genuinely
seem to know what they're after what
they're trying to accomplish
and that's something that i think we
lost with some of these 64. i can't get
away from this thing
i think we lost that with some of the 64
player maps and um battlefield 4 was it
was just too many damn people on
a map that just didn't justify it now
there were some apps that justified 64
people um
the uh
refreshment memory the train map um
somebody help me out here called mood
railway
uh gomud railway was thematically very
weak the train was just a single engine
and it just wasn't exciting and you
weren't fighting on it but it was a
large map it definitely justified lots
of tanks and vehicles
uh and i think it was one of the maps
that supported it
metro operation metro when they redid it
i still think there's no business for 64
players in operation metro it's just
one person cannot make a difference
on a map that small with that many
people and it actually gets boring like
you're actually in so many fire fights
so consistently that
the pacing is just it's it's quite
frankly dull
that's how i felt about it like shooting
people constantly isn't necessarily a
good thing
that's why you and i have been playing a
lot of rainbow six each it's because
rainbow six siege is all about the build
up and the anticipation and
uh and the kills come quickly and they
they're meaningful and you know
battlefield's a different game but you
can still have a
a similar idea where
you know like how are these kills
meaningful i just shot like 20 guys in a
row
does that matter did i accomplish
anything did i help
with the objectives you know it's it's
that's what you need to ask
yourself
oh
shot right off the turret so yeah that's
a long answer to uh
the question of
64 players so yeah if they want to do
more players they could do it like
planetside they could channel it better
i'd be fine with that
but they need to justify it i've always
i've always thought that um you know one
of the things that they used to do i
would say was that they would um justify
the objectives like
you know certain vehicles would spawn on
objectives there might be fixed weapons
at objectives um
in a few cases i know they did it in
1943 but in a few cases there was like
an air strike that you could call in
from an objective
and
having capture points in that
traditional conquest style that were
valuable
was something
that made
you know a large player count match make
sense because you kind of always knew
where you were as a team if you looked
at the map and you knew okay well we're
not controlling
air support we're not controlling
anti-air but we are controlling armor
like you kind of have a sense of where
the map was and where the
where the match was going
but i kind of felt like they moved away
from that uh starting with battlefield 3
where there was this sort of attempt to
make every map work with every mode and
instead of having the sort of
purpose-built maps that we see
here like you know this is a you know a
rush map that we're looking at right now
like
it is through and through like a
a
well-designed rush map
and
having objectives that seem senseless
was something that really drove me crazy
like caspian border was like
there was a point where i'm thinking why
am i defending a flag in a ditch
this flag in this ditch doesn't mean
anything
and all i'm doing is wasting my time
exactly um i think you know one thing
that the earlier battlefields nailed
better
die one of the things that earlier
battlefields nailed better was uh
objectives at bases that were meaningful
like this is the tank spawn base this is
this is the bombing base this is the
base that has the um the really heavy
uh
in place gun you know like when you took
a base it had meaning it wasn't just
like cat remade caspian border where
it's like hey this uh m.com is in a
ditch be excited for this ditch you know
like
why
why would i ever be excited to take that
objective what is at that objective
that's meaningful there is nothing of
value
yeah i mean even you know
as simple as a game as it was
battlefield 1943 you know
there was the you you felt you
understood the value of the of the
objective when you went after it and
uh on twitch google was asking is there
anything you guys would do to make
people concentrate more on the objective
and i think that's what it is it's it's
the
is having the objective itself have
value
so um
one thing that i i just always have to
point out about this map and in bad
company in general is
destruction is something that we've
thrown around a lot and i feel like
people say to dice often but i don't
feel like dice
really understands what people
mean when they say destruction
and what they mean is on this map like
look at the ground right here look at
the ground like look at the town you
know
where this match is at based on how just
effed up this map is right that's the
truth i mean the one of the
i in a lot of games my pet peeve is when
i start my first match of the night i
end up in the at the tail end of a match
that is about to end
but one of the things that i love about
you know especially bad company too was
that as soon as you spawned you knew the
score like yeah
there is the terrain is deformed
buildings are on fire there's nothing
left you kind of you kind of know what's
going on just from looking at it you
don't have to look at a scoreboard you
don't have to
go to a pause menu you can just look at
the environment and say oh yeah this is
this is pretty messed up and it's not
just destruction for destruction's sake
it's like dropping bridges it's blowing
up houses it's messing up sniper nests i
mean it's
destruction that changes the way around
is played
that's what you know when everybody says
they want destruction in a battlefield
game that's what they actually mean they
don't mean the pretty
like surface oh they don't mean the
pretty surface level gloss
oh yeah i mean if you ever dropped a
bridge out from underneath a tank on
wake island you totally understand the
value of of that kind of destruction
get some
don't die get some man don't die
oop i did not switch the right gun there
so yeah throw it back out to the chat
like what else what else do people want
to see in this announcement
because i'm curious you know i mean
that's what we want to see but i will
say that they are trying to please a lot
of different people over the years
they've really expanded the series yeah
i mean the chat's actually very diverse
and i think that's something that in its
way
i don't know if you would say it was
totally a good thing or totally a bad
thing but
you know between
bad company between the newer
battlefields 2142 vietnam and then
like that those are completely different
groups and people and also you know late
in the game the introduction of uh
um team deathmatch which we didn't
really see until battlefield 3. um
you know they're i mean a lot of people
will i think rightfully criticize them
for trying to emulate call of duty at a
certain point to expand their audience
and then you can blame them for trying
to explain their audience but
it definitely seemed to water down the
battlefieldness and it and again like
the biggest problem is that suddenly you
have to please a lot of people
and also
uh
i would also argue that there wasn't
they'd there wasn't an effort to unify
the audience you know like hardline was
released but they continue to support
battlefield 4 throughout the entire run
of hardline um
i know on pc the hardline community
really shrank pretty quickly
um and if for no other reason because
battlefield 4 was still supported
yeah it's interesting they handed over
support to battlefield 4 to dice la who
actually i think it's genuinely agreed
on by most major youtubers did a
fantastic job
fixing fixing up that game
for me personally it was kind of a too
little too late kind of a thing i you
know i just didn't have the the patience
to wait for that game to be improved
um
especially if you you know compare it to
you know at the end of the day
battlefield 3 turned out pretty well and
if you look at this game i mean this was
well so well supported throughout its
entire run i mean
they gave you purpose-built maps and for
for free they repurposed existing maps
every once in a while and kept the game
fresh
let's see
there's a little talk in the chat
mentioning i see i see a mention from uh
synax 808 of star wars battlefront
as a failed attempt of battlefield 5 oh
sorry wait wasn't star wars battlefront
a failed attempt of battlefield v i
think battlefield i'm sorry i think
battlefront was a failed attempt at
marketing
um
i think it's kind of funny we were
talking about this the other day one of
the early trailers
of a
battlefront was a dude playing with a
storm trooper in the snow and i think
oddly enough that was the most accurate
representation of what we ended up
getting was what they meant was it
wasn't supposed to be the authentic
battle
it wasn't supposed to be the authentic
star wars experience it it was supposed
to be
the authentic star wars toy experience
like you playing with star wars toys in
your bedroom
that that is that is what it ended up
feeling like to me was like when you sit
in your bedroom and go
play you don't play with your ewok
village that is exactly what they
delivered and it wasn't a battlefield
game i think
the problem is people saw
dice
they saw dice and they thought
battlefield but
i don't know i don't know i don't know
who allowed that perception to continue
i don't think it was a battlefield game
i think it was an arcade and it almost
seems like it was never supposed to be
yeah
i again i battlefield
over the years has had some pretty bad
marketing i mean again i think the
lowest point in battlefield marketing
was levolution levolution there was a
time when they they actually did a whole
entire tv spot on jet ramming and how
great jet ramming is they're just like
completely out of touch with their
community
um
so yeah i think marketing has never been
the best on battlefield i think they
they got themselves some pretty graphics
and i love this map but that that
inbounds border is way too
conservative on the on the left side
there sorry
you walked out of bounds for a second
yeah so mr joshua on youtube asks how
does gamespot know it's battlefield 5.
the answer is we don't
yeah so we i don't know like everybody's
talking about like it's battlefield v
but that's just a placeholder um
there's a decent chance it'll be a 2140
what it would be at this point three
there's a good chance i mean i doubt
it'll be a bad company after hardline
because hardline didn't really land with
the core battlefield audience i might be
totally wrong about this but i mean i
think that on some levels if
if it was a sort of for the fans game we
would be getting bad company 3 with full
destruction and it would be
that it would it would be sort of
picking up where this game left off
um i think that if we look at
battlefield 3 and battlefield 4 there's
definitely signs of going towards the
future with you know in some of the dlc
and in
easter eggs in battlefield 3.
yeah
again um both end game the last dlc in
battlefield 3 and final stand velocity
and battlefield 4 heavily hinted at
another 2140-something title
um
we're just calling it battlefield 5 as a
placeholder the actual marketing
material just says battlefield reveal
event so that
that means it can be anything so
ease one two three one two three five on
youtube has actually what i think is a
very fair question which is what would
be the difference between bad company
three and battlefield v the story line
um i think that's actually kind of a
good question because i think when
like as fans when we say we want bad
company three i feel like
there's a lot of things bundled up in
that idea like there is this idea of
you know when it comes to single player
it's maybe a campaign that doesn't take
itself as seriously and gives you a
little bit more creativity of what you
can do
uh
within the the confines of a mission
when we're talking about what it means
for
the multiplayer experience i think we're
talking about purpose-built maps
that are designed for their game mode a
rush map is a rush map a conquest map is
a conquest map and then of course we're
talking about
this level of destruction that
you know is
utterly devastating
yeah i think it's a combination of more
personality more destruction
um i i personally liked all the crazy
filters
in bad company because i thought it gave
it personality i know some people
thought that uh battlefield 3 went too
far with the what was it the
green tones
you got to get out of that tank yeah i
need it i need a good tank crew
oh
this is not going to i don't know i
think you're in trouble here
i don't think my team is going to win
this rush but yeah i mean the reason
that i love rush so much and i've always
have loved rush is just it tells a story
i think it tells a story every time it
takes you through a
a map that has different areas every
area tells a different story has
different um
types of combat some of it's close some
of it's long range some of it's urban
you know some of it's not and i think
ultimately that is what was appealing
about rush
and i would like
i would just i want maps in battlefield
again the telestory
um
you know just conceptually on some level
not just there's a train that got lost
in the field
well and that's the thing is that i
think that it's the
um
the
there are changes in terrain to ranges
and changes in structure
um
changes in advantage for the defenders
and the attackers from one set of crates
to the next
and
all of those things um mean that each
time you play the map it's going to play
out a little bit differently and each
time it plays out a little bit
differently it basically is telling a
different story and that's what
makes it possible to keep playing you
know bad company two over and over again
no i don't know we've talked a lot about
rush let's talk about
what makes a good conquest map because
there's the whole original battlefield 2
crowd that would love nothing more than
just fantastic conquest right
so i think
i think one of the things that makes a
good conquest map is going back to
another conversation we're having with
uh wake island
is meaningful conquest capture points
conquest capture points that
like check out how like messed up the
middle of the map is now this is all
like this is all no man's no man's land
right so that destruction is meaningful
yeah it is changed the way this is being
played sorry so
wake island there was one of the
conquest points was the air base and
that is really meaningful because you
need that air base to get the airplanes
right
some of them were tank bases that's
meaningful because you need
you need the tanks so
you know i think what's what they could
do to go back to really good
conquest
are just just that here's the air base
here's the tank base
you know i would love if they go further
and limit ammo and tanks and say here's
the the ammo cache for tanks
and um here's the you know the airplanes
have to land and refuel every once in a
while or something that would keep
people who are really good
from you know
destroying the map constantly but yeah
like i think that's what makes the best
conquest maps are not just here's a
ditch go capture the ditch it's
you know here's this powerful gun
emplacement
this map you want this the night maps
yeah okay so
one of my fondest memories of this game
was i played this map
at i wanna say
maybe three in the morning i was on the
defending side
there were three of us on the team
and there was a rotating cast of maybe
two or three people on the other team
over the course of 90 minutes
on the first set of crates and we were
just sniping on a ridgeline and we
completely leveled this forest with the
mortar strikes
and
well okay that was fun but
the main thing is is that you can really
clear out this entire forest if you have
the time to do it what you have just
described is back to the meaningful
destruction idea that we're talking
about um so there are a couple things in
chat that i want to address um one is
and this is something we've talked about
amongst ourselves many times um
outcastcowboyz420 asks um do you think
they'll add
day to night or weather changing
um and i think we kind of both agree
that that would be a good thing um if
for no other reason than
going from
just re the replayability of a map we
get a little bit of this in rainbow six
siege where there's day and night um i
don't think they've gone far enough so
like in the original rainbow six siege
oh he's gonna die from a grenade
in the original rainbow six siege
trailer um it was more than just day and
night you would go in at night and the
lights would like destruct and flicker
and create confusion
the problem with these types of night
maps are that they don't really have
much meaning it's it's you can basically
see as far as you can in a day map so
it's it's more equivalent to when people
who do film production shoot day for
night
right then actual meaningful this is
dark you really do need to use
um
oh now this is reversed
funny i flipped the helicopter controls
but now it it also flipped this
um you need a meaningful day for night
not just kind of fake day for night well
i feel like
in some cases they they did okay i mean
i thought in battlefield 3 tehran
highway was good but i mean mainly the
thing is is
playing the same to me playing the same
maps
day or night or different weather like i
know that in battlefield 4 there was
like a little bit of you know what was
it dawnbreaker started at night and it
became day over the course of the map
like
that was kind of cool
but i like the idea of
you know before the match begins and
you're you know changing your load out
or whatever like you don't yet know what
you're in for like you don't know
that it's gonna be
nighttime daytime it might be raining it
might be snowing like visibility might
be bad visibility might be good
and that completely changes things i
mean you know
if if it's foggy you can run a long way
in the open before you might get hit but
if it's broad daylight then you're you
know sniper bait and
on any given map having these kinds of
changes would improve the longevity
i think
aaron is intent to survive this
house breach um
what else do we have in the chat um
oh so master the hero on twitch was
asking what did you think of operation
outbreak
um i personally didn't play it but aaron
you did refresh my memory this is the
community map and the reason why i bring
this up is
the reason i want to call attention this
question is because
uh not so much that there was a
community
uh
influenced map or whatever but more to
the
fact that
this series in my opinion
is
the reason we got out of the world war
ii rut
because
of mods and the
um the
modern combat mod for 1942 sort of
changed things in my opinion
and i think the idea of involving the
community more
and maybe even having community actually
mod created maps would be a good thing
yeah i mean i can't fault dice la for
trying to work with the community to
come up with a cool map um that i
thought now that i remember operation
outbreak it was the one with the um
the waterfall i do think they had a mis
they missed the epic parachute jump
which i don't understand why ever since
battlefield 3 we haven't got an epic
parachute jump because the epic
parachute jump was goddamn epic
um and i think the community suggested
that that epic parachute drop but i know
overall i think it was a great jungle
map and it proves that they can do
jungle um
people had originally requested urban
and they said it just basically takes
too much budget to do urban uh which
that's why i'd rather have them not have
a single-player campaign and just spend
their budget on urban urban maps
um yeah it was cool and
some of their best maps though i have to
say is just
when dice went back to battlefield 2 and
redid wake island or redid
um
dragon valley those those were all
recent ones like
a lot of their good stuff has been
regurgitations of old
full content
um
it means that
i don't know what that says to me is
actually
what they should probably be doing is
just
releasing an hd remake
of um
battlefield 2. i think if they were
smart and if they liked money
they would just do that
i i like even if they just did it on top
of everything else
i just can't imagine
people wouldn't buy it
i mean you'd play an ac remake wouldn't
you
uh yeah i definitely would
but you know i'm not that picky
i mean there's a lot there's i mean
there's a huge fan base for battlefield
2. people love that game
all right sally fourth
um let's see marley j in the twitch chat
says the vietnam dlc
for this never got the praise that it
deserved um do you agree that it never
got the praise that it deserved
i mean i would say that it the
the awesomeness that it was was not
repeated again and i think that was
horribly unfortunate i mean we
i i was hoping that the vietnam dlc was
like sort of a proof of concept that you
could have
a thematically different dlc that really
sort of revitalized playing the game
and there was also like
compartmentalized like you would just go
and play
battlefield bad company to vietnam
you know it wasn't mixed in with the
other maps
oh i mean vietnam was a it was i think
it was hands down my favorite dlc in all
of battlefield just because of what you
said it was a it just completely was
different everything about it was
different
uh the guns played differently they
didn't have oh they didn't have sights
um which was interesting because so
actually i don't know if you remember
but in bad company too you had to pick
between a gun sight and an ability
um
so suddenly you could just focus on your
abilities and not worry so much about it
uh
it was just yeah i was one of the
strongest thematically driven map um
dlcs
and it felt like you know i mean it was
a remake of
battlefield vietnam which was a full
game
yep we've got the mr grommet and youtube
chat saying there's too many games that
do futuristic warfare
i mean that's what you were saying
earlier is you just kind of feel like
titanfall did it and did it well and it
doesn't really need repeating i mean i
think that there's maybe always a little
bit of room for a little bit more of
everything out there but i don't feel
like
you know
i need that from battlefield right now i
think that's the thing is that for my
sort of confidence to be restored in
this franchise i want to see what it
does best
i think what it's done best is sort of
what we're seeing right now as you're
playing um
you know for futuristic
you know games the what titanfall did
really well was
create a new sort of
feeling of movement with all of the
parkour stuff and then having that
transitioning between
uh infantry and titan and adding the
bots like all of these things that it
did
that were actually kind of novel
um
to me made it totally appropriate that
it was a futuristic game um i don't feel
like
just changing from
you know
traditional weapons to
energy weapons and otherwise you know
maybe adding a planet or a different
type of vehicle
really is enough for me to feel like i'm
playing something that's futuristic i
think having mechanics that feel
futuristic
now that was a nice rpg snipe
is more valuable
sorry i got distracted by that awesome
rpg snipe kinda proud of myself i'm not
gonna lie
now i'm gonna go get killed
god this game just felt so good
that's what i love about this game it
just feels good like it's a game that
just has a personality
it knows it knows what it wants to be
it's
you can you can bring down these
buildings like
if i bring down this building it'll kill
all of these guys
you could run in as a um like a c4
sniper and just get in there and like
blow out a building from underneath
the enemies it just is like an
incredible thing that we just haven't
haven't seen
um and we've seen that destruction in
battlefield 4 but there's never a reason
for these guys to all be hanging out on
a rooftop like this right
like why would anybody in battlefield 4
be on one of these rooftops
so much smoke and debris just like
just [ __ ] going down oh oh
like a whole squad over there
oh
that ran out of bullets i thought it was
a good thing
yeah i mean you there were buildings
that could be dropped in battlefield 4
but there was never really a reason for
people to be on those buildings
um except for the one exception being
uh siege of shanghai
which
i thought was cool in concept but nobody
ever thought about what happened when
the building came down like hey this is
awesome until the building comes down
and then it's not as good of a map
then there's a garbage pile in the
middle of the map yeah like why why was
that compelling
oops
yo
so alex sutton in the youtube chat says
um i may be controversial in saying this
but i really liked all the customization
in battlefield 4. it allowed lots of
specialization um i actually agree with
that i
i totally liked being able to
sort of
um kit things out differently
but i do also recognize that that sort
of
got away from what the game we're
playing right now did which was have
such class specific
um abilities and traits that it was
balanced by class instead of by weapon
um
like you know the class in this game
that can bring people back to life is
the class that has the machine gun which
is the most difficult to control also
the recon class having the mortar strike
kept other recon classes from camping
and also gave the recon class like a
more meaningful role in the game other
than just standing in a hillside and
also recon class should have always had
more credit for spotting
because they should be getting huge
points for spotting because that's what
they're supposed to be doing right
that's what recon does and i think you
know them never getting any significant
point bonuses for spotting always kind
of boggled my mind like you have to
think about the classes in terms of what
a class is supposed to do
and then reward players for for doing it
you know
and to their credit i think that um dice
did make some efforts uh
after the release of
battlefield 3
um to balance the point system a little
bit more
they did make some efforts like uh
if i remember specifically um they
increased point score for suppression
as an example of that expression was
controversial
separation was very controversial and i
know that you and i do not see eye to
eye on suppression that's fine i mean
battlefield can be different things to
different people
um
in terms of customization though yeah
like i don't think that's ever a bad
thing i i think that letting players
turn characters into their characters is
it's a good thing it's always a good
thing yeah like they opened up the
carbines and the dmrs to every class as
well as the shotguns right i think that
was okay it worked they came in a little
while they can't get in here and destroy
this building so just note what they're
trying to do now
is just destroy the building from a
distance which again was a way to keep
matches moving in this game
um to keep people from getting bogged
down at checkpoints because if you
couldn't capture the m-com you could
blow it up yeah you could destroy the
income from afar
that was a
legit strategy
and again it comes back to good good
flow
like that's what you're looking for in
these games is
games that channel players through their
maps in meaningful ways and in fun ways
but yeah battlefield 4 i you know as
much as i didn't like the map design
battlefield 4 i would never argue that i
think the controls were smoother
um and better and i think the
customization was better like there were
a lot of aspects of battlefield 4 that
were that were actually improvements on
battlefield 3 just not the map design
the map design i
i just didn't think it had any strong
ideas of what its maps wanted to do or
be
and that was my biggest problem with it
the one that i liked
also the guns got a little too friendly
one that i mostly liked conceptually was
flood zone where
you know if the if the dam got taken
down then the map would actually flood
with water i thought that was a cool
idea i don't i wouldn't say that it was
very necessarily very well executed at
the end of the day um depending on the
game mode but um
i thought that was a cool idea
oh just lost the mcom because of
destruction
and everybody's dead everybody be less
dead
nope
get up get up
why won't you leave
oh okay now everybody's dying
all right a quick shout out to yardy 78
for saying love valparaiso and bad
company too just gotta
just gotta say right on
right on
i love all that coming to you just
really this this one was the game for me
and this this game is full of so many
great maps
plus i got an mg come on
how can you not love an mg
i do have to say though i did like the
addition of uh bipods
they didn't always work well but the
idea was a good idea another good idea
that didn't work perfectly oh i love
bipods bipods are great um they allowed
recon or sorry they allowed a support
class to
lay down
uh recon accurate long range fire with a
heavy barrel attachment
it was
a genuinely great
great idea
and again you know i think um
uh battlefield 4 actually because of all
the support i got from dice la later on
does have a big following right now
because they did
you know they did fix a lot of the
problems and they did a great job at it
and i think they made that game about as
good as it could be
um
you know what i mean i even liked
hardline i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna say that out loud i like
i think
i think what's what no
oh come on
so okay the game is not
perfect that bad company was not perfect
by far
uh a lot of a lot of things were
improved in later editions when it comes
to immediate gameplay um i liked
hardline i think the problem with
hardline was that
it just didn't have enough content and
after two betas
uh people had already played it by the
time it it released right
like hardline had been done
because it didn't have enough content it
had been done by the time it came out
but the guys over at visceral uh
genuinely added a lot to battlefield
they
um added much faster vehicles they
actually
fixed the sound through floors bug that
was them
they added really fun like one in ten
thousand animations that just kind of
brought the bad company style humor back
into the game
there was a lot of fair enough i think
that's fair enough
although i think you know you and i both
kind of burnt out on that game a little
bit quickly a little bit more quickly
than we did on these
previous incarnations anyway and again i
think that's just because there wasn't
enough content um and i think
you know later on the game just
recognized that it's audience m60 thug
life you know i think later on the game
embraced their call of duty crowd too
much and that's why they ended up
turning off a lot of their battlefield
fans
because
um you know battlefield people want
meaningful gunfights they don't
necessarily want gunfights that just
are non-stop i don't know
like
just
point blank range fests i guess be the
best way to put it
um so i think uh we don't have a ton of
time left and i think we should talk
about you know what we think would be
some
positive things for battlefield v or
whatever it is
um but i'm just gonna call out one more
comment before we talk about that which
is
chris a says ryan and aaron bad company
three
um games that last 20 minutes or games
that last one to two hours what do you
feel about match time because i'm i
really liked you know last summer
playing planetside 2 a bit and i liked
that
it was sort of like one long match
um and some of my favorite experiences
and memories from playing previous games
were games that went abnormally long for
abnormally long amounts of times and
that includes times where there was a
low low enough population that ticket
bleed was slow and other times where
when we had custom servers the
you know the tickets were cranked up to
max or the time was cranked up to max
what do you think aaron do you prefer a
short match or something medium or
something long are we talking about in
an ideal world or how much time i
actually have in the night
because realistically i've got an hour
and that's it um you know i'm a family
man
i got kids and a wife who i gotta make
not feel neglected and also be a gamer
so i got an hour
but the most memorable games i've ever
played were it was like a two-hour round
of obliteration where i was afraid the
server was gonna crash and i ended up
winning
um like once or twice we told the other
team look like we're all afraid we're
gonna lose our progress just take the
bomb and go to ours and let you have it
but i forgot that i had put a bunch of
c4 uh or sorry a bunch of um
mines in a canal and so blue i blew up
their boat
and then grabbed it and probably pissed
them off with a helicopter and won the
match so like that was the most
memorable i've ever played
so i
the answer is um
custom servers that's the answer
let people
let people have their custom servers
right away don't wait
on it
and let them
let them tell you how much time they
have to play
all right uh
yeah caleb in the youtube chat is uh
giving us a little uh little heat for
not talking enough about the new game um
so let's let's switch it over for the
last few minutes here
um
i think that uh if we look back over the
last few
installments
of the the series that
for as much as uh you and i even have
complained from time to time i think
there have been a lot of good things um
and we like the direction the
customization is gone
we like to see them roll back the way
they handle destruction i think
um
in terms of time period the hint right
now is that it's gonna be future
do you feel good about future where do
you want to go
um i i would rather have vietnam to be
honest
i think
photo photogrammetry and
battlefront
was gorgeous on endor and i think that
in battlefield would be incredible if if
it's not at the expense of
like that kind of did this see this what
i'm looking at right now if you can do
photogrammetry without this type of
destruction
um i'm sorry with this type of
destruction then that is exactly what i
want um
if you if you can't then screw
photogrammetry i don't i don't care if
it looks that good
but yeah i would rather have vietnam
than feature setting
um
asymmetric maps
meaningful classes and weapons
and uh
you could get that in a 21 what would be
at this point 43
but
um oh man a lot of guys going down
around you as as you've put it as you
put it already um near future's been
kind of done to death
i feel like we're going to get a
titanfall 2 at some point
uh which i think does near future or far
future better than just about anything
i've ever seen
so yeah i don't know i don't know if we
needed 2143
how about your thoughts ryan
um
i
basically feel the same way um i mean
i'm not necessarily totally opposed but
i don't
also have a ton of confidence that
future is what i want to see from this
developer
um
i i think that they where where they
have shined is in you know the in
historical and modern combat
um although i know there are a lot of
big fans of 2142
and
that that game does exist um
but in terms of the
new game
i'm hoping that uh they
do more with uh mode specific maps and
purpose-built maps we haven't seen that
in a while they've been trying to like
you know
fit
all of the game modes into all of the
maps and i think the battlefield 3 4 and
hardline all suffered from that
um
it just certain modes don't work on
certain maps something else that i would
like to see that i was a big fan of in
titanfall was
a mixed mode playlist
playing one mode on a
constant cycle of the same maps over and
over again to me was actually kind of
boring
especially since dice is
sort of has a penchant for creating
playlists on their official servers that
are identical
and uh never change up the map order
and having something that was more
random and unpredictable was actually
really cool
um
so why don't you read off just real
quick and then we'll end our stream read
off all the battlefield games that have
been so far
and have people in the chat say just if
they had to pick one of those which
would they
okay which one would they pick if for
the remake and or not sorry for the
remake for the for the next one so now i
noticed that you don't have heroes on
here yeah i was gonna say and i'm also
noticing that you know on some levels i
just want to say just
just to get it out of my system that i
think that
plants versus zombies is the best
battlefield this is a excellent
battlefield game
okay so
um here we go from the top 1942
vietnam
battlefield 2
2142
bad company
1943
bad company 2
battlefield 3 battlefield 4 and hardline
so that's the full list i'm seeing a lot
of bad company one seen battlefield 2 in
the chat
um
got some 1942 call out too
42 was a great arcade like
how did i not kill that guy
um what 42 was the
was the 42 no no 43 was the the more
arcadey one that they did but it was
fantastic it was it was arcade in
battlefield fashion
definitely a lot of call outs for
battlefield 2 i mean battlefield 2
on a lot of levels i think was you know
the one that introduced everybody to
this type of
it did
and
i mean
my only issue with it was that i feel
like their decision to walk away from
like mod tools was
not not ideal i think there was so much
creativity in the mods for 1942
um
i kind of wish that that would come back
i swear this guy i've shot like five
times
i definitely see some 2142 in the chat
i see a 1943 in the chat
i see some random numbers that aren't
battlefield games
i mean would 2142 just would that just
end up being battlefront but the
battlefront game that people wanted
that's an interesting question i wonder
if that would be the case
i mean uh people in the chat like would
you would you
expect or hope that 2142 would kind of
be what battlefront wasn't because
that's all i wanted battlefront to be i
wanted battlefront to be the
2143 you know that that we wanted
i just wanted it to be star wars themed
and they had you know walkers and
everything that would be in that we just
ended up with a really arcadey game
like a really arcadey
like kind of shallow game
i don't know what do you think about
vietnam i know a lot of people say world
war two why why or why not vietnam
me personally i feel like we did it
recently enough
but
maybe not
there's definitely there's definitely
some people who'd like to see just like
what we talked about earlier in the
stream you know some
some just hd
like remake yeah i think an hd remake
regardless of battlefield 2 would be a
very smart decision on dice's part
i mean again like i don't know you hate
money
yeah i mean look the the the battlefield
vietnam expansion for this game was i
think three or four maps and they
reskinned everything with new weapons
all this blah blah blah like i would
take that
i would take that i would take a full
game that had like four of those modules
whoa
i tracer darted it and it just came
right for me
well that's one strategy
he's on the other side of the stand dude
did we get him
yes we got him
uh let's see suzanne christian
christensen in the chat says uh north
versus south korea i think we've talked
about this before that has not that has
not come up as a battlefield game we
have not seen the
american war in korea before and sure i
am totally in favor of that honestly i
think
you know you get a
it's not replaying all the same
uh
you know world war ii maps i mean world
war ii has way more famous battles i
mean i think i only really know about
the chosen reservoir campaign
in korea so i i
wouldn't be able to recognize much
beyond that and maybe
landing at inchon or something like that
but um
i would be totally in favor of of uh
doing the
doing that conflict as well since it's
by the way you know tragically
under reported or under talked about in
you know at least american war history
i mean one of the interesting parts
about
um korean war is actually americans were
vastly under equipped
but they still had better stuff than the
north did yeah chosen reservoir the
chinese i'm sorry and the chinese did
yeah like we actually fought a war with
china if nobody told you that if nobody
covered that in history class the united
states literally fought a full-scale war
with
full armies against china
that happened whoa is that new
i don't know i don't know if i've seen
that before
um
but i missed it and and uh
news flash we we lost the first round
real bad oh yeah
yeah that was a tug of war territory
so yeah i don't know i don't know if
that's too close to home for people
um but sorry home front is kind of
you know
and
in a fantastical near future sense sort
of doing that
fair enough
fair enough
also you know we we might actually have
that war so that might be a little too
close to help
alrighty so i think we're about ready to
wrap this up maybe uh let's see you guys
still have
plenty of tickets on the attacker side
there i don't know
you can try and wrap out this round
i mean i'll talk about i'll keep going
as long as people want to talk
battlefield because
i have loved outfit for a long time and
again i kind of soured on four and i'd
like to come back to the series
i i don't
i want to be hopeful
um i will be completely honest that
you know battlefront
ended up not being whoa it was a double
shot you see that he got both of us in
one dang good shot dude
and that was that that sniper rifle was
my weapon of choice always in this game
we need to talk about good sportsmanship
i think that's something that's been
kind of missing in gaming now for a
while like
people dropping out because they're
they're losing that's just like old
school like just don't be don't be a
sore loser go back and remember what it
was like when you played high school
sports
if or maybe i don't you're maybe you're
still in high school but yeah we need to
have a return back to good sportsmanship
and in video games where people treat it
like a sport like this is
you're playing against other human
beings
um if they're better than you then
they're better than you you know
and if you're better than them you're
better than them but
i i've been seeing a lot in siege lately
where people just act like real sore
losers when they get killed in a game
you're playing a shooter would you get
you know in soccer if someone scores a
goal on you
like their skill was better than yours
and you should be gracious about that so
there's one thing i'd like to see in the
next battlefield
it would be a return to good
sportsmanship don yes and in the
gamespot twitch chat it says
sportsmanship in war
yeah well i mean if you want to talk
sportsmanship in real wars called the
geneva conventions there's [ __ ] that you
cannot do to people to other human
beings okay so i'll add this is
something that i would like to see i
would like to see dice be willing to do
and actually commit to
um
um
asymmetric teams
oh you got it oh that thing's tackled
like a christmas tree
i mean we used to have it you know
different weapons different factions and
then eventually it was everybody had to
be able to have access to the same stuff
i'm kind of against it i liked having
asymmetric
factions in the battlefield games
i would definitely want to bring that
back
uh yeah asymmetry is nice i think it it
causes you to be a more tactical player
yeah i mean if you i cause my thing is
is let's say that one side is more
technological than the other and another
one has
let's say
other terrain advantages like
you just have to work out as a team how
to play your faction and work it out
i mean if i remember if i remember right
the way that vietnam handled it was
um the uh
um the the vietnam side the vietnamese
side or nva side whatever
um did they have like trench systems and
they had some really cool routes like
they had cooler routes than the
americans did but the americans had
definitely on some of the rush matches
for sure
like it's conferring advantage through
not just firepower it's referring
advantage through map design and other
means
that guy's controlling the helicopter
and i badly want to drive out there and
knife him i wonder if i can steal a
vehicle
all right this match is winding down
down to the last 12 tickets so check it
out by the way even though this is a
rush match like look at this map this
map has a story the story is it's like
you know it's a place where they uh
break down ships or it's like a derelict
shipyard this probably used to be a bay
and the water ran out you know like
there's there's a concept to this map
and look like i know where we are in
this match because the base the hilltop
base that i started on is completely
jacked up it's almost completely
destroyed
okay with the last seven tickets we're
gonna start signing off i want to thank
everybody for joining us for the stream
today um make sure you
follow like subscribe and uh what have
you in all of the appropriate places
subscribe on youtube follow us on twitch
um come back for more streams we have a
live show every tuesday at 2pm that's
our talk show hosted by danny o'dwyer
you want to check that out super cool
and we'll be covering more of the
battlefield coming up may 6th is the
announcement at 1pm pacific and we'll
have plenty of coverage for that for you
guys
next week yeah thank you so much for
joining us uh for this uh battlefield
five stream we'll just put on quotes
and
we'll find out on may 6. thanks
everybody
all right thanks a lot
you